libyans have started burying those
killed in the tsunami-like flood
disaster in the eastern city of Downer
more than 5 000 people have died and at
least 10 000 are still missing after
heavy rainfall caused two dams to burst
a huge wave of water crashed through the
city sweeping away everything in its
path authorities expect the death toll
to rise in what is the country's worst
environmental disaster in modern history
while the scale of the disaster is
becoming clearer through satellite
imagery now this was Dana on September
the 2nd there are four Bridges across
the Wadi Darna River including a main
Crossing along the Waterfront the river
itself is dry for most of the year now
the city looks like this you can see how
the river has overflowed and destroyed
the bridges and the buildings in its
path silt has spread across the city of
80 000 people Malik trainer begins our
coverage with this report from the
capital Tripoli please
in unprecedented catastrophe entire
communities in the eastern city of Darna
have been swept away by floods or
reduced to Rubble
people here are still coming to terms
with the aftermath of storm Daniel
it brought record rainfall and two dams
holding huge amounts of water birth
sending a giant wave towards the city
this child asks people if they know
where his mother is but no one has seen
her
thousands of others remain unaccounted
for bodies washed into the sea can be
seen in the distance but it's too
dangerous to recover them for now death
toll is huge it might reach 2000s really
but we don't have a different number
right now the loss is being felt across
the country here in martyr Square in the
capital Tripoli flags are flying at half
mast the government has declared three
days of national Mourning many have
gathered to pray for those who have died
in eastern Libya
he received news yesterday his sister
and her entire family were killed in the
floods he's come here to pray for their
souls
the officials are responsible for all
the lives that were lost why because it
was clear that the dams had a problem
and needed renovation there were
warnings why didn't they fix it they
knew a storm was coming may God punish
all the officials from both sides for
This Disaster aid from Western Libya and
a few countries is beginning to arrive
at airports in eastern Libya
says his government is committed to
rebuilding homes that were destroyed
today we allocated a budget of more than
515 million dollars to start rebuilding
people's lives and impacted areas If
These funds are not enough to rebuild
Darna and the other cities we will
allocate more everyone is doing what
they can to help Libya has two
governments but people here hope that
through this tragedy the country and its
rival politicians can finally unite and
put its people first Malik trainer Al
Jazeera Tripoli and Malik joins us now
from Tripoli and Malik obviously a very
delicate operation for the for the
immediate now one would say it's a
search and rescue operation but has this
changed now to a recovery operation
it appears so so I mean what we're we're
not seeing our survivors being pulled
out of these homes that were destroyed
because of the flooding I mean the
pictures that we're seeing and some of
them are extremely graphic are of dead
bodies uh being pulled out of homes that
were completely flooded I mean some of
some of these uh homes and pictures that
we've seen at the water reached up to
the third story so you can just imagine
the wave that came into the City and
just
devastated the city of Darna us so uh
you know rescue uh operations or or
search operations are underway to
recover bodies
at the moment authorities were able to
reach the city of delna yesterday uh so
we're waiting to see and understand how
devastating this flood was
Malik thanks so much for the update of
course we'll continue to check in with
you through the day